You've just learned how to write some very simple programs and how to correct
errors and to deal with all sorts of fussy details. Let's step back a little
bit and think about what a computer can do for us. A computer can execute an
algorithm. That's a technical term for a recipe of instructions that are
unambiguous, executable, and terminating. Well, those are big words. So let's
see what's going on. Unambiugous means that the recipe can be interpreted in
only one way. Executable means that its steps are those that a computer can
actually carry out. And terminating, of course, means that they come to an end.
That's all pretty abstract. Let's look at a concrete situation. You need to buy
a car. You have two choices: this beauty over here, it's cheap, but it has
terrible gas mileage, or this sleek one over here, expensive, but great
mileage. Which is the better buy? I'll show you an algorithm that makes that
decision. The first car costs $15,000. And the second car costs $30,000. So, it
looks like we should buy the first car. But, not so fast. The first car gets 10
miles per gallon, and the second car 50 miles per gallon. So, what do you
think? Which car should I buy? Do you think I should go for Car 1 or for Car 2?
Or, in the end doesn't it really matter? Or maybe you don't have enough
information to give an exact answer. Tell me what you think.